it's good
unprisoned is your most unlikely buddy
comedy really inspired by Tracy McMillan
my dad was in prison most of my life and
the show is what if I had had my dad
come to live with me hey baby girl
my character Edwin seems determined not
to make the same mistakes that he has
made in the past it's basically an Odd
Couple they love each other but they
have been estranged for lots of years
and now learning to be in each other's
space is overwhelming you know from a
therapeutic standpoint avoid it
attachment is what is all this
psychological mumbo jumbo with my
character we wanted to redefine how
people look at how they judge how they
perceive ex-felons tonight's my TED Talk
would you like to help me pick something
to wear I think a dress it's not very
feminist just because a woman wears it
doesn't mean it has less value page
there's nothing wrong with looking
pretty you know that you're right about
the weirdest things sometimes
but they have a lot to figure out a lot
of trauma and emotional damage has been
inflicted over the years
let me explain
right now I was feeling so fast because
based on past experience I don't know if
I should believe you should I can I no I
don't think in charge of being annoying
I'm really excited for the relationship
between me and my grandfather because
he's so fun I've been such a fun
character
[Music]
you have a driver's license just a
permit I might have a proposition for
you I'm team finwin Finn and Edwin are
everything you know I start a car
that was a key
the relationship between Paige and Edwin
involves in this really beautiful way
she begins to realize there are two
sides of the same coin I've had a lot of
Pinch Me moments working with Carrie and
Delroy it's been a dream realized I
think that you're doing a great job and
I don't say that enough
I think it's so fun to be able to watch
a show that is complex and
thought-provoking but also heartwarming
[Music]
you have to then be someone who's never
been before I'm hoping that it opens up
a discussion into
when and how people genuinely deserve a
second chance a second shot at life
it is all about love everybody needs a
healing of some sort and the way you get
to it is through love
[Music]